Hy hello everybody and welcome to
episode number 12 of my 1 hour flipping
challenge today we're going to be doing
the Abyssal sire for 1 hour uh so some
of the drops we're looking out for
obviously the abysal dagger the abysal
whip but on top of that um it has a load
of very good consumable drops like seeds
runes
herbs Rune weapons ton of other things I
could do besides that and um yeah let's
get started okay we are ready to start
we have 1 hour on the clock we will be
flipping Abyssal sire drops only for 1
hour let's
go okay so what we're going to start
with is definitely going to be the
Abyssal dagger um that is the most
expensive Abyssal drop I can flip pretty
much uh abysal dagger uh we're going to
try starting it
at I'm looking at the OS buddy graph it
looks a bit higher so we'll try
9630 and I don't know 96 36k try to buy
one of those to start
with um next up actually someone was
telling me to do Snapdragon seeds Okay
so we bought them for
25500 and we sold them for 2450 that's
still pretty good actually and 200 seeds
it'll be an easy 200k assuming they all
flip do another 200 RAR seeds as
well one GP margin that's pretty nice
okay uh next let's check the Abyssal
whip okay so we bought it for
1511 and we sold it for 1501 pretty bad
margin byy a couple to start with but ah
it's not a very good margin okay next up
we could just start flipping some runes
one 217 that's pretty good actually
10,000
okay we actually bought all the snap
dragon seeds so that will be good let's
pop those in with the others um that's
not too bad for battle stabs
anyway that is a 25 GP
margin let's try
it we can afford 500 let's see how that
goes okay all the law runes have bought
that was quite
quick and kind of interested if it'll
actually let me check the margin but I
think we're selling up for 221
what
the
weird well it dropped down to 219 but
we'll put it in for 221 and see if it
raises up while we're waiting okay I
think we're going to do some Onyx bolt
tips for
8510 start just like 200 or something so
I'm not sure how quickly they'll
actually sell or buy well we got 24 of
them already that's pretty
good okay so we have the majority of the
RAR seeds actually bought uh so we'll
put them back in for let's see two 2,000
20,000
sorry so worth 5,000 cannonballs I'm not
sure what the limit is on that anyway
okay we already bought 5,000 cannon
balls was quick and we're selling them
for 229 that was a great
margin see how quickly these actually
manage to sell 96
60k now there's not a lot of these trade
oh my God a bunch of stuff just
completed okay okay let's start with the
onx bolt tips we can just get rid of
those okay 200 onx bolt tips going in
law runes nice we got
a five GP margin that 50k right there
first actual completed flip
honestly and the abysal whips have all
bought
153k let's just hope we get something
from it
300 sure death run has a very good Marge
on it as
well
265 not quite enough
for 10k of them but that's okay
and now we're pretty much just waiting
we have no money left just waiting for
offers to
complete okay um so actually we sold all
the Onyx bolt tips uh which is pretty
sweet how much money did we get in total
from that that was actually really quick
I feel like I've done this item before
and it's taken forever um I don't even
remember I thought we got like a 1K
margin on that so it's almost
200k um yeah let's do more definitely
for
sure and another 200 sounds reasonable
see stores are taking a long time to buy
so I think I'm just going to take those
out okay we sold a bunch of stuff uh
cannonballs have sold that's 5K only uh
super
restores got actually about 15K from
that so not too
bad uh death runes totally bought sell
for
273 okay we've actually bought all the
Onyx bolt tips already that was so
quick bought them for
856 double check we're buying selling
them for again 94 95 that's a great
margin
494 okay now I'm kind of thinking of
just giving up on these Abyssal weapons
this is just not sold at
all lower this down
God
damn just goes to show that these
expensive items you think would be the
best to flip really are not
like uh I think I might just pull this
out this is not bought at
all and we'll try one
more abysal
dagger
9700 that is kind of pushing it
actually sold an Abyssal whip sold
another Abyssal whip I mean we're only
getting a 2K profit on this I think not
even we're pretty much just breaking
even it's a little a little annoying
but wow was sold so quickly though even
if we get a 10K margin that would be
okay like a bit of money at least 294
sure oh my God I bought wasn't even pay
attention uh we bought pretty much all
the bolt tips all in one go someone must
have had them stockpiled
awesome oh wait no that was a sell offer
what the hell I remember buying these
wow okay so we made a cool 200k off that
that's awesome
sweet
um dang that went really well uh let's
go let's do some more of
these just try 200 to see how it goes
and we've totally sold the death runes
so broke even there blood runes have
pretty much all
bought 159 and 10,000 Cosmic
runes um battle stops all totally bought
they buy really quickly sell them for
8846 um so 1769 is what we're selling
them for only 5K from the 500 or 200
battle stabs actually not terribly good
but 04
five oh [__] we bought all of the oh my
God can I check the snam Dragon Seed
yet
no I'm just going to put him in for what
we bought him for I
believe we bought all of these Onyx bow
tips oh my God hope we can sell all
these in time 4
94 94 94 that's right by the way we have
24 minutes left anyone was wondering
we'll take out these RAR seeds and just
kind of get rid of them arrows that's
one thing I forgot to do last
time CU this does include the rare drop
table which does have a couple good
things on
it okay Rune arrows
114 and
10,000 and also nature runes forget
those that's usually an easy
20K
271 269
yep now just the amount of space left is
a bit of an issue oh nice we got another
large chunk of the onx P tip
sold
perfect um we actually have one spot
available in 7 mil I don't know what I'm
doing I think Co is a two GP
margin 10K is kind of just a safe bet if
you don't actually know what the margin
is um yeah we're com about spots here I
think a crap I was just about to take
that out but we bought a
amount uh Rune arrows still buying which
is nice oh my God onx P tips of pretty
much all sold we'll take that out
perfect that another pretty large amount
from the Alex bll tips that is probably
what's going to carry us this
time okay all the nature runes sold
that's nice get us some spots
available take out some of these magic
logs 10 v six oh my
God [__] you
take out these magic logs stupid
pointless magic logs
now our Bo arrows have all bought and
we're selling them for 116 I'm pretty
sure
2K okay and we have sold off the blood
runes that's
nice and coal we sold off half of
it okay sorry we're just kind of
messaging to Clan chat here let's see
what is going on um bought all the
battle Saabs okay okay that's good and
uh we'll see what we can sell them for
again 88 of course undercut
8844 magic logs [__] wish I hadn't done
magic logs we actually could stand to
lose a good amount if they drop by even
a couple GP all right we got under 8
minutes left I think we're just going to
focus on selling the last bit of stuff
we have
okay well magic logs all sold that's
nice coal I think we're just going to
pull out we're not buying
anymore um super stores might keep that
going actually those are working pretty
well nicely actually and the reros have
sold we got another 20K
there okay we're down to 35 seconds left
I don't think the rest of these battle
staffs are selling but uh H whatever
we'll probably lose 10 20 on them but
that's fine
um I don't know I'm a little mixed about
how today's episode went I didn't flip
any of the actual items I mean you saw
the pistol whip had a 2K margin on it
pretty much and then
the ab bugeon I don't even know I didn't
manage to buy any of those not sure if I
didn't have the right price or if they
just don't trade a lot cuz it's about
100 every day or something but um yeah
there we go timer's done let's have a
look at how much we actually made pull
up these battle
stabs of dump them I guess
guess okay wait let's just put them in
for
that instantly sold 13 mil not too bad
okay so we have a 30 mil cash stack
let's see how much we made for 1 hour of
flipping Abyssal sire
technically oh wow we actually got 858k
so that's quite a bit more than I
thought um it's amazing those are just
random drops pretty much that was not
even any of the actual items had have
been able to flip Abyssal whips for like
a 50k profit or even flip one or two of
the Abyssal daggers um that probably
would have been easily over 1 mil uh but
still as it stands pretty happy with
858k considering all I flipped for runes
seeds and most of all the Onyx B tips
which is probably over half of that
profit um and yeah hope you guys enjoyed
and I'll see you guys in the next
episode